[Musique]
bonjour et à toutes et à tous merci de
nous rejoindre pour ce forum des députés
européens
donc je suis heureuse d'être en
compagnie de collègues de la délégation
renaissance et du modem pour vous
accueillir et pour faire un tour de huit
coups de ces sujets qui nous ont
beaucoup occupé dans ces derniers mois
puisque nous avons des crises multiples
nous sommes arrivés et avons pris nos
fonctions au moment du bric site et nous
avons affronté de plein fouet la crise
du coronavirus que nous sommes en train
de nous sommes en train de nous occuper
chaque commande à des niveaux différents
donc je vais commencer bien sûr par
faire un petit tour de table je suis
laurent sfar indique députée européenne
je suis en compagnie donc dans ce tour
de table 2 j'ai aperçu si les brunes et
sur ma gauche qui va elle aussi se
présenter christophe grudler marie
pierre vieu grain et catherine chabaud
voilà je vais peut-être passer la parole
à mes collègues je vais peut-être avoir
un petit propos liminaire pour vous dire
quand même que donc nous sommes au
simple de cette délégation renaissance
au coeur d'un groupe central que nous
avons contribué à reformer qui sape qui
ne s'appelait heil 2e et qui est devenu
rignault qui épinglent centrale qui
défend tout à fait les valeurs que notre
mouvement démocrate et notre
positionnement politique du mouvement
démocrate occupe sur l'échiquier
français que nous sommes 23 au sein de
cette délégation sur une sur un groupe
politique de 97 donc que nous agissons
et que nous informions très directement
sur les prises de positions qui sont
prises au niveau politique par le
parlement européen puisque 23 sur 97 à
fait l'opinion ça fait des positions
politiques
et puis comme ce groupe il fait des
majorités et bien une opposition pèse
très directement
alors chacun d'entre nous occupe de ce
budget différent je vais mettre ma
parole à mes collègues alternativement
pour qu'ils présentent un peu leur
action je vais pas commencer peut-être
parce qu'ils brûlent un qui est plus
plus directement
je suis en charge des questions sociales
dont s'occupe aussi marie pierre baux de
rennes sylvie est ce que je peux te
passer la parole d'une donne aussi son
sentiment sur cette période très
exceptionnel que nous avons traversées
volontiers bonjour est ce que vous
m'entendez oui pour moi c'est un peu
saoul mais ça va je trouvais bon depuis
ce matin j'ai eu quelques problèmes
techniques
pour être franche je vais aimer et
espérer que ça va être mieux là mais
voilà c'est un papier c'est le problème
de technique
donc je suis sidibé et je siège à la
commission emploi et affaires sociales
une vice-présidente du groupe renew
[Musique]
comme tu l'as dit laurence peut-être
plus spécifiquement dans les sujets
jeunes conquois emploi acacias voilà la
parole à mes autres collègues parce que
hp alors je vais reprendre la main pour
passer la parole à marie hier deux
reines pour que vas tu te présentes
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous nous
entendez bien ravi de retrouver les
quatre autres collègues du mouvement
démocrate au sein de la délégation aux
naissances donc moi je siège dans la
commission du commerce international
j'ai plaisir d'avoir été élue vice
présidente de cette commission
donc tout ce qu'ils les questions
relatives à la mondialisation des
questions d'actualité hier le mercosur
par exemple et puis j'ai le plaisir
d'être aussi avec sylvie dans la
commission emploi et enfin dans la
commission des pétitions qui est peu
connu mais qui pourtant un rôle
essentiel pour rapprocher l'europe des
citoyens
bien sûr par christophe qui est notre
représentant masculin puisque délégation
très féminine à l'europe
catherine à toi pour parler de des
sujets de des combats oui merci laurence
et bonjour à tous
alors il y à un décalage j'entends
attendez je retire mes oreillettes
parce que sinon je m'entends en décalé
écoutez moi je suis d'abord ravi de vous
retrouver je siège dans trois
commissions la commission environnement
où j'ai travaillé récemment sur un sujet
de décarbonation du transport maritime
sur la loi climat et bientôt sur
l'économie circulaire est également sur
la biodiversité et voilà pour la
commission environnement sur la
commission pêche également où je
travaille en ce moment sur un avis sur
un rapport d'initiative sur l'impact des
déchets mara sur les pêcheries et puis
en commission développement ou en ce
moment je travaille on s'est beaucoup
intéressé sur les les
les partenariats que si l'union
européenne avec les pays en
développement sur la pêche les accords
de pêche et en ce moment je suis
rapporteur pour mon groupe je suis pour
mon groupe les ce qu'on appelle la
négociation post cotonou la relations de
l'union européenne avec les pays acp cp
afrique caraïbes pacifique
voilà du meilleur général j'essaie de
faire monter le niveau de la mer au
parlement européen et à la commission
européenne parce que je j'ai c'est de
prôner une stratégie pour la mer pour
l'europe voilà alors moi c'est compliqué
parce que j'ai un vrai un très gros
décalage entre mon ma parole et ce que
j'entends dans l'oreille donc j'espère
que ma femme avait reçu une balle hors
en effet je pense qu'on a tous un peu
plus ou moins donné des problèmes
technique mais quand même on est très
content d'obtenir d'elle et de parler du
problème à nice mans avec ce que nous
aurons rejoindre ce soir ce soir non
parce qu'on est amis et l'a d'ailleurs
je vais prendre la parole pour
christophe grébert puisqu'il a aussi des
problèmes se connecter donc je voulais
lire que christophe bourret lui toute la
thématique et la dimension industrielle
énergie dont j'ai une maman important
visiblement ne peut pas intervenir
immédiatement mecs voilà je voulais dire
que c'était aux destinées des sujets
très importants sur la souveraineté
industrielle le leur implantation d'une
activité après cette période de navires
us qui nous a fait prendre conscience de
toutes nos faiblesses en la matière bien
donc je vais peut-être revenir à cette
période que nous que nous allons
traverser ces grandes décisions moi je
pense que en effet la question que nous
avons résolu et ce sur quoi on peut être
relativement satisfait c'est que nous
avons une dimension d'efficacité que
nous avons mis je crois au en priorité
de notre action comme je le dis dans tal
al bull nous avons a vraiment un rôle
politique et dans le vent dans cette
danse est dans ce moment de relance nous
avons pu porter la volonté de ce qui a
été fait pour ce plan de relance urique
aubry plane qui a pu être décidée à
l'échelle européenne par les trois
parties constituantes que ce soit le le
parlement qui a porté cette volonté
initiative relayée par l'allemagne et la
france puis décidée par le conseil
européen est validée finalement donc ça
c'est un des grands succès quand on peut
s'enorgueillir et maintenant c'est vrai
que nous avons l'argent de ce plan de
relance donc il va falloir faire des
choses alors peut-être je vais passer la
parole à marie pierre derenne pour
étouffer ce sujet un tueur là la
question de la souveraineté puisque on a
parlé de notre point de souveraineté au
plan international de souveraineté en
matière des changes souveraineté en
matière d'auto groupes industriels de
santé ou et avoir un peu ton sentiment
sur ces questions merci beaucoup
laurence alors je vais essayer aussi
peut-être de compléter et de dire des
éléments que christophe aurait pu bien
me dis que moi mais on travaille très
souvent ensemble parce que nos
commissions sont liées justement sur
cette notion tu évoques laurence de
souveraineté on le sait c'était
extrêmement important et c'était aussi
une ligne que le modem a toujours
défendu que le président de la
république dans son discours de la
sorbonne défend des amas chaîne du co
lead s'était assuré à l'union européenne
une autonomie sur la scène
internationale et le choc du coc vide
nous a renforcés dans nos convictions
il faut que l'union européenne soit
beaucoup plus uni pour pouvoir être
beaucoup plus autonome sur la scène
internationale donc c'est tout le
travail qu'on doit mener à la fois pour
développer une politique industrielle à
pau localisant certaines de nos
industries que ce soit dans le domaine
de la chasse neige que tu me rendes sur
le domaine de l'alimentation et il faut
donc travailler sur une politique
commerciale et une mondialisation qui
soit juste qui soit durable et qui soit
loyale donc c'est tout le travail qu'on
mène au parlement européen et et faire
en sorte comme je le disais aussi
d'embarquer véritablement tous les états
membres sur cette position
et c'est souvent ça qui est plus
difficile et je crois qu'il faut le dire
à nos auditeurs
parce que on a souvent et on est on est
souvent à l'avant-garde la france sur
des positions comme le fait de demander
que l'accord de paris soit une clause
essentielle dans nos accords commerciaux
mais l'enjeu c'est de bâtir un capital
politique suffisant pour embarquer tous
les états membres sur cette position
et c'est ça qui est souvent le plus long
en tout cas dans la construction
européenne il faut faire preuve de
patience il faut faire preuve de
conviction et c'est ce que la délégation
connaissance le groupe renault
faut il nous faut bâtir une autonomie
stratégique européenne sur tous les
sujets clés pour pouvoir justement ne
pas être dépendant à la fois de la chine
et à la fois des états unis parce que
l'union européenne c'est une voix
singulière sur la scène internationale
serait énormément de sujets vous avez dû
suivre le discours d'ursula von der
leyen cette semaine le discours sur
l'état de l'union où par exemple sur la
question environnementale la question de
la transition écologique
elle a avancé le fait et c'était déjà
une ambition et c'est encore plus
prégnant maintenant que l'union
européenne soit le premier continent
neutre en émissions carbone donc on a un
rôle clé à jouer à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne et l'union européenne
à 1 suite à un rôle clé à jouer sur la
scène internationale pour embarquer les
partenaires pour atteindre ses objectifs
donc c'est ce à quoi moi je m'emploie
ressort de la commission commerce
international et je serai ravi de à la
suite des échanges de revenir un peu
plus justement sur les enjeux tels que
les négociations avec le mercosur mais
aussi tous les échanges qu'on peut avoir
avec la chine à l'heure actuelle parce
que j'ai la chance d'être rapporteur sur
la chine dans notre groupe
et là aussi il faut qu'on ait une
position beaucoup plus uni pour pouvoir
dire à la chine de changer son
comportement que ce soit sur les
questions de concurrence d'agrès et que
ça soit aussi sont des engagements en
matière climatique et de respect des
droits de l'homme mary pied
cette dernière coin me permet de faire
la transition sur cette question des
transitions puisque au delà de la
reconstruction de la pub après conomie
qui est traitée dans le cadre de ce plan
de relance
il ya bien sûr cette notion de
transition qui est au coeur de des
différentes politiques européennes sur
lesquelles nous travaillons que ce soit
la transition numérique mais aussi et
surtout je dirais cette transaction
écologique a été très développé dans le
discours sur l'état de l'union de
d'ursula von der leyen puisque elle a
encore marqué une volonté et une
ambition sur la transition avec cette
étape 2030 qui a été réhaussée par
rapport à la réduction de gaz à effet de
serre et je crois que bon la mieux
placée pour parler de ce sujet c'est
catherine chabaud a acquis bien sûr je
vais passer la parole cette transition
elle doit donc ligue et toutes nos
évolutions tout dans notre plan de
relance que ce soit en matière
industrielle agricole et de soutien à la
biodiversité ni dans nos politiques
environnementales et tu en as parlé bien
sûr dans nos nos futures relations
commerciales échange donc catherine de
te passe la parole sur le sujet oui
alors merci laurence je retire mes
oreillettes il faudra me faire signe
pour arrêter de parler parce que je ne
vous entendrez plus ou sinon j'ai
vraiment ce décalage
alors il ya une chose qui est importante
à savoir c'est que l'union européenne
s'était donné un cap avec le green deal
avant la crise du coc vide
l'objectif étant d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 et avec des
objectifs intermédiaires
c'était c'est tout l'enjeu de la loi
climat sur laquelle nous travaillons à
l'heure actuelle avec un objectif pour
2030 de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que la commission
6 et s'est fixé à 55% que nous nous
demandions à 60% dans la commission
environnement la crise du coc vide
finalement avec l'arrivée donc du plan
de relance et j'allais presque dire une
opportunité pour accélérer la transition
écologique parce que le plan de relance
va permettre finalement de financer des
innovations pour la transition dans tous
les secteurs alors celui que je connais
mieux c'est le secteur maritime où on
vient de travailler sur un texte
législatif qui avec une ambition de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de co2 de 40% d'ici d'ici 2030
avec aussi la technique lui ions du
transport maritime dans ce qu'on appelle
le marché du carbone et qui est est ce
qu'on appelle le ts en anglais et qui
devra donner qui devrait permettre
d'abonder aux ressources propres que
l'europe pourrait se donner en tous les
cas c'est ce que pousse le parlement
européen que l'europe demain puissent
rembourser sa dette grâce à ses
ressources propres et donc le marché du
carbone en fera partie
alors toute la toux le green deal touche
effectivement la décarbonation des
secteurs très émetteurs gamma il y en a
il y en a plusieurs il ya le transport
maritime et la part dont les le
transport en général puisque le
transport maritime représente uniquement
3% 3 7 % exactement de la totalité des
émissions mais le transport représente
30 % si on conjugue transport routier
très émetteurs le transport routier ses
72 % des émissions de tout les moyens de
transport donc le transport le bâtiment
est très émetteurs bien évidemment
l'agriculture et l'énergie et donc le
green deal a pour objectif de
vise la réduction des émissions dans
tous ces secteurs le green deal
s'intéresse aussi à la reconquête de la
biodiversité alors sur les sujets aussi
sur lesquels je pousse l'objectif c'est
de ne pas parler que des forêts pour moi
c'est aussi de d'investir dans ce qu'on
appelle le blue carbone puisque les
écosystèmes marins et côtiers participe
à l'absorption du carbone et en même
temps fournissent la moitié de l'oxygène
de l'atmosphère
et puis la transition c'est aussi
l'économie circulaire sur laquelle nous
avons travaillé alors je pourrais
développer tout ça encore longuement
elle doit se décliner dans tous les
compartiments du jeu y compris dans les
dents les le commerce qu'évoquait
marie-pierre tout à l'heure mais
également mois en commission
développement
il s'agit d'avoir une transposition
déclinaison de notre green deal dans nos
relations futures avec les pays en
développement
et ça on s'attache vraiment a poussé ces
sujets là voilà je pourrais développer
longuement mais éventuellement peut-être
je pourrai répondre tout à l'heure aux
questions vincent chauvet je suis donc
l'animateur je devais la tête en bas
j'étais en noir et blanc
la bière a tous je crois que notre ami
christophe goodyear qui est comme moi de
bourgogne franche comté qui est député
européen de belfort à a eu des
difficultés à se connecter à peut-être
un microclimat sur la bourgogne franche
comté alors entoure en tout cas j'ai
bien pu suivre le début des
interventions pense que les internautes
vont commencer à poser les questions en
ce qui me concerne en tant que maire
modem de la ville d'ottawa encore
bourgogne en salle et aux questions
européennes
ce que je représente les maires de
france au comité européen des régions
qui est une instance consultative qui
travaille sur les dossiers que
sont à l'agenda du parlement européen ou
de la commission et nous faisons
notamment des rapports et le green deal
est au centre nous aussi nos
préoccupations parce que du niveau
européen au niveau national jusqu'au
niveau régional la transition écologique
doit pouvoir se mettre en place à tous
les échelons les chaque question et
complémentaires l'un de l'autre
moi j'avais une question je n'ai pas
encore reçu de questions internes mais
j'avais une question justement sur les
ressources propres
je crois que catherine tout à l'heure à
parler de ressources propres
c'est-à-dire finalement les impôts qui
vont pouvoir rembourser l'argent du plan
de relance on a parlé des ressources
propres liées à la taxe carbone
je crois qu'il ya aussi des ressources
propres qui sont envisagées sur les
droits de douane extérieur on a parlé
aussi de ressources propres sur les gars
fassent hurler sur le numérique
est-ce qu'il faut une combinaison des
trois comment justement on va pouvoir
rembourser au niveau européen ce plan de
relance est et comment on va doter enfin
l'union européenne d'un vrai budget
propre basée sur des ressources
européennes et non pas sur des
contributions nationales
je laisse un peu la question ce que
marie pierre veut peut-être en dire un
mot sur les différentes formes que
peuvent prendre ses ressources propres
et comment on peut faire contribuer le
comment on peut faire des impôts vert
est relancée financer le plan de relance
vers part d impôt vert
alors c'est cette semaine au parlement
européen justement nous venons ont
proposé prononcer sur un rapport sur les
ressources propres
effectivement et je pense que sylvie va
revenir sur ce point là il est essentiel
que le plan de relance ne permet de john
ne fasse pas payer la contribution aux
citoyens et qu'on assure une transition
que ce soit donc écologique qu'elles
soient numériques qui soient justes et
qui ne laisse personne de côté
et là je pense que sylvie va pouvoir
répondre et et non éclairée aussi sur ce
point là mais pour répondre à ta
question sur les ressources propres
effectivement c'est essentiel que les
européens tous les sept ans donc on
négocie le cadre annuel et puis tous les
ans il faut voter le budget annuellement
il ne faut pas qu'on soit contre ils
dépendants en fait des bon vouloir de
chaque état membre
et c'est pour ça qu'il nous faut des
éléments des ressources qui ont vont
directement aux européens et qu'ils
soient indépendants du bon vouloir des
états donc tu as évoqué différentes
pistes il y a tout d'abord la taxe sur
les services numériques
on n'appelle pas que ce gars fin parce
que on l'a vu dans le contexte du co
lead les géants du numérique ont tiré
davantage de bénéfices et il faut qu'ils
paient leur juste part c'est normal
c'est essentiel donc il ya cette
proposition du parlement européen il y a
également la volonté de taxer les
pollueurs et ça répond à notre objectif
d'assurer véritablement la mise en
oeuvre du green deal et c'est donc la
taxe sur la table qu'on appelle taxe
carbone mais que son vrai nom c'est en
fait en fait le mécanisme d'ajustement
aux frontières et tout le travail qu'on
va devoir faire moi je ferai dans la
commission commerce international
s'éveiller à la compatibilité de ce
mécanisme avec l'organisation mondiale
du commerce
donc il ya tout un travail essentiel à
mener et puis il ya il ya d'autres
propositions une taxe plastiques etc ou
là il a un peu plus de volonté commune
de tous les états membres de le mettre
en place mais ça sera justement un
travail de longue haleine où il faut que
le parlement européen qui lui a toujours
été clair sur la volonté d'avoir des
ressources propres
même le combat face à aux conseils parce
que la commission européenne nous avait
dit qu'elle ferait des propositions à
l'horizon 2021
mais on sait que là où les enjeux seront
plus difficiles c'est au sein de
certains états membres qui ont bâti en
fait leur modèle économique si je prends
l'exemple de l'irlande ou des pays bas
sur un petit peu un système d'évasion
fiscale
donc il faudra que la loi du parlement
européen soit forte et il faudra qu'on
travaille comme tu l'a justement dit
vincent aussi tu es membre du comité des
régions avec toutes les institutions et
avec les acteurs locaux pour arriver à
cet objectif d'avoir des ressources
propres qui soit le plus importante
possible pour ne pas faire payer le plan
de relance sur les citoyens
mais bien sûr les pollueurs et sur ce
qui ne contribue pas à l'injustice
sociale et fiscale
merci alors justement j'ai l'impression
que cette crise va profondément changer
l'europe et de manière permanente et
notamment au niveau du social je crois
sylvie brunel
vous travaillez actuellement vous pouvez
vous plaidez pour un mécanisme permanent
qui au delà de la crise pourrait
justement au niveau européen
aider les états membres à traverser des
chocs sociaux des périodes de récession
comment ça peut se mettre en place parce
que là aussi il faut des ressources
propres et puis est ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est crédible est ce qu'on
va pouvoir y aller avec l'ensemble des
pays membres
c'est que peut-être les différences
d'appréciation des politiques sociales
sont grandes entre les états européens
oui je dirais que indépendamment de
cette image heures voilà qui depuis
[Musique]
monde entier nous avions déjà des axes
l'europe sociale
d'ailleurs est ce qu'on devine humour
sous la forme d'un la marque alors en
garde conditions écologiques digital
combattants liés au volet local l'emploi
les compétences
moi je dirais que je travaille plus
comment sur plusieurs sujets de mes
peurs legs ou démunies puisque dans le
peuple grec nous votons battre 40 10
insuffisant les plus démunis notamment
l'aide alimentaire à faire de l'aide
alimentaire en france
c'est par des eaux au vert avec cette
crise pandémique augmentation où la
demande est de l'île en clair donc c'est
un physique pour des lillois est
quantitativement et qualitativement donc
ça c'est un jeu le te tue avec les
associations c'est au tour du père
banque alimentaire secours populaire ou
autre sujet majeur qui nous concerne
alors vous savez peut-être que depuis
l'essai ligne en direct
j'ai de l'emploi des jeunes à près de la
gare venez vous nous souhaitons
augmenter mes outils en améliorer le
fonctionnement des salles pour les yeux
d'emplois jusqu'au premier emploi
indépendamment des fonds européens
mais pour lui du champion faire avec les
autres pays
donc toutes concernées au front
théo problème que des bonnes idées qu'on
va prendre l'eau en italie ou dans
kontich redden ce qu'ont fait les cent
pas recueillir pour nous donc 46 planès
les compétences et compétents le corps
au groupe et individualités qui est
estimé aux portes-en-ré intéressant et
plutôt c'est le nageur et enfin nous
devrons continuer à lutter contre les
marchés intérieurs c'est important mais
il ya une mobilité même si la copie de
disney un peu un coup d'arrêt quand même
les trouver dans ces zones y est on a
les premiers affrontements près de
venise il en met des règles en place au
niveau européen pour éviter
naveen sociale d'où le travail imminente
sur le salaire minimum
il n'y en a pas pour arriver à une
convergence être exemplaire voilà en
quelques points ce que j'ai et sociale
il faut pas que doublé dans la prendre
notamment il laurent cents par action de
30 juste ni accompagner les travailleurs
massimo là où va le voir transformer des
appareils de production à charbon de
protection merci alors laurent justement
est-ce que
je travaille aussi particulièrement sûr
sûr sûr ce fonds d'ajustement et sur
l'impact sur les territoires des
mutations économiques et de la crise
est-ce qu'on peut aller plus loin je
crois que j'ai aperçu tout à l'heure
christophe grudler le député de belfort
qui est apparu il est il doit être très
content que le lion de belfort et était
désigné comme monument préféré des
français mais je ne le vois plus à
l'écran et pourquoi peut-être aussi
élaboré sur ce point quand il reviendra
en ligne laurence oui mais sur ce point
ça rejoint peu que je disais en
introduction sur la l'obligation
d'efficacité des politiques européennes
et parmi les politiques efficaces de
l'europe il n'y a bien sûr tout ce qui
constitue les fonds structurels et les
fonds régionaux
on l'a vu au début de la crise est à une
rallonge budgétaire très importantes sur
les plans régionaux de 37 milliards qui
a été réallouée pour casque aux premiers
effets de la crise
donc cet argent il est arrivé dans les
rayons et il a été rien n'est sûr du
match ont presté cité à ce sujet et on
peut ouvrir le débat
on a vu qu'il ya toujours cette
difficulté pour les régions d'être très
transparent avec le démontrons comment
l'action de l'europe se concrétise c'est
un sujet que nous avons et que nous
débattons régulièrement
deuxième point sur cette question des
plans régionaux et des fonds structurels
c'est quand même le deuxième but n'est
de l'europe après la pac il va être
également fortement mis à contribution
dans le cadre des aides du plan de
relance puisque en effet il y a tout un
volet du plan de relance qui s'appelle
réactive yuki et docks à hauteur de 47 7
milliards il va être fait de chance
culturel et comme le disait steve il ya
un programme très important qui est le
mécanisme de transition juste qui va
être composé de trois piliers qui va
accompagneront les régions dans leur
transition écologique donc
nous sommes en train de finaliser le
succès sur le fond de transition lui
portent sur la transition des
compétences d'une évolution des
compétences et nous allons travailler à
perdre très rapidement sur les
investissements dans les nouvelles
infrastructures d'énergie de transports
c'est un sujet très important que ce
soit vers le public vers le privé
mais en août et christophe pour à
étoffer le propos sur ce sujet et voilà
donc cette question des fonds régionaux
du fonds structurels sur lesquels nous
travaillons pour les quelques on va être
tout à fait clair et on sait que là on a
encore une question est qui va être je
pense largement débattue dans les
élections régionales pour amorcer c'est
cet effet des cas cités concrétisation
des fonds régionaux au plus près des
citoyens
merci crédible c'est tout après passé
pas si christophe nous arrange toi je le
je l'avais vu par le le déconfinement
tweet est ce que certaines régions
d'autres gens pourraient bénéficier des
fonds de l'union européenne mais
rarement remercier l'europe ou le fonds
européen pour cette action est en fait
sa tribu et le la paternelle de blanc de
relance
il ya des investissements importants qui
en fait viennent de mesures votées au
niveau européen
est-ce que christophe est encore dans
l'euphorie de la victoire
il est également attentif à des sujets
d'avenir sur notre territoire qui sont
qui sont importants notamment le
ferroviaire c'est lequel l'union
européenne a son mot à dire et qui dans
notre territoire
vraiment
sur le développement et sur la
transition énergétique
d'autres domaines qui m'intéressent
il est là c'est le sait le spatial et je
voulais justement peut-être parler de
ces filières d'avenir dont on est en
train de de nous parler de manière
récurrente dans les médias notamment sur
les batteries électriques notamment sur
l'hydrogène est ce que le plan de
relance va être le plan de relance
européen va être l'occasion de créer de
nouveaux champions industriels à
l'échelle européenne pour justement
asseoir notre souveraineté technologique
et redonner de l'emploi relocaliser
l'emploi dans nos territoires des
emplois qu'on avait peut-être laissé
partir sur des filières qui s'était
développé à l'extérieur de nos
frontières européennes peut-être sylvie
brunel je suivais alors on en passe il
vit sylvie on nous entend pas alors on a
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
oui oui on n'entend pas ce que c'est un
sujet magma ce sont me sert notamment du
breton qui travaillent donc commandé
clair sur l'analyse et d'écosystèmes du
lieu important est adaptée en termes
d'impact vous vite impact transition
écologique et un pack véritable acte
bien évidemment autant de ses plans ce
support des nouvelles compétences
des compétences faut réorienter fusée
par sujet les rénovations
annick l'on va conduire parce qu'on m'a
jamais autant dans quoi il va pouvoir
mobiliser et ses seuls points
d'adaptation qui va passer l'année
diplôme ou formation tant que les
personnes sortent déjà un petit peu tard
pour besoin ou qu'on a cette bd à faire
et c'est trop long tail en france et en
europe va engendrer un nouveau ça c'est
le signe positif
mistura bois conditions de mobiliser un
travail d'ensemble au niveau européen au
niveau en plus de chaque état membre et
au nez vous des territoires à voir que
ceux travaillant avec les branches
professionnelles
il est par exemple on y mange avec
business sur tous les plans d'action des
parois hier en droit diplômé es avec des
clarines aussi vraiment donc voilà on
plie comme au jeu pour être analysés
mais ça va être un sujet qui va aussi
mais autant de signes d'espoir et
d'optimisme pour nos concitoyens parce
qu'on a eu cette crise qui s'est rajouté
merci marie pierre tu voulais peut-être
compléter sur justement là comment la
politique commerciale eau et d allah
relocalisation et à faire en sorte qu'on
retrouve des emplois m supplémentaires
sur sur ce que vient de dire s'il vit
est ce que comme on faisait tout à
l'heure ce que nous aurait mieux
explicités christophe à qui
malheureusement aller à des soucis de
connexion et on aurait bien aimé qu'ils
ne partagent tout son travail avec comme
on le disait et comme vous le voyez
aussi la force de la délégation
renaissance c'est d'être dans toutes ces
commissions au parlement européen et de
travailler dans le même sens pour
arriver justement à cette aune autonomie
stratégique et faire en sorte que
l'europe soit les championnes mais pour
répondre à ta question sur l'émergence
de champions européens par sujet il faut
voir là aussi la vision différente des
états membres et il faut voir aussi
qu'elle est le tissu actuel économique
au sein de l'union européenne
et c'est vrai que malo nous en europe on
a plutôt un tissu qui est basé sur des
pme et c'est elles qui font la force de
notre marché intérieur et pourquoi on a
pas de champion européen c'est parce que
notre politique de concurrence
à l'heure actuelle ne permet pas cette
émergence là donc c'est tout un travail
aussi qu'on mène avec dans la commission
économie et finances pour réformer la
politique de concurrence parce qu'à
l'heure actuelle notre politique elle ne
permet pas ses champions européens parce
qu'on se focalise seulement sur le
marché intérieur est on le sait bien la
concurrence maintenant elle est mondiale
avec la chine mais avec d'autres acteurs
qui sont des pays émergents donc tout le
travail qu'on mène c'est faire évoluer
cette politique de concurrence et bien
prendre en compte le marché mondial est
donné en fait les clés à meaux nos
entreprises à nos pme pour qu'elles
puissent être compétitif sur la scène
internationale c'est pour ça que par
exemple à l'heure actuelle la commission
européenne a lancé un livre blanc sur le
contrôle des subventions étrangères et
comment elle impacte notre marché
intérieur
donc c'est essentiel de modifier à la
fois toutes nos politiques sur le volet
commercial sur le volet industriel pour
avoir d une autonomie stratégique et sur
le volet commercial pour que l'union
européenne m soit autonome soit
indépendante
du coup ça me permet de dire que c'est
le débat qu'on continuera tout à l'heure
à 14h30 au cours de six des démocrates
merci à catherine chabaud voulait
peut-être aussi rajouter sur la filière
industrielle mais version maritime
comment elle a aussi tiré profit y ait
anticipé un développement des filières
industrielles maritime
oui merci
effectivement c'est dommage que
christophe ne soit pas avec nous il
aurait évoqué les quatorze filière qui
touche alors c'est amusant parce qu'en
fait ça n'a pas une seule qui soit
maritime elles le sont toutes
au passage les quatorze filières
identifiées par le commissaire thierry
breton pour une relance industrielle
européenne et qui te concerne aussi bien
le tourisme le numérique que la santé
l'agroalimentaire ou l'aérospatiale et
la défense concernant le baril team que
je connais un peu mieux en fin de compte
on pourrait tout à fait imaginer et
c'est ça fait partie des sujets que je
pousse pour que demain émergent des
projets industriels paneuropéen
je prends l'exemple du de la
construction maritime aujourd'hui les
cargos ils sont plutôt construits en
asie on ne construit en europe plutôt
que des emprunts surtout en france en
tous les cas des paquebots il ya plus de
2,2 numérique s'essayer à un peu plus de
complexité dans ces navires là et qui
sont construits plus tôt en europe qui a
le savoir-faire
demain on pourrait éventuellement voir
émerger en europe et ça va ça va être le
cas des navires de transport maritime
d'une nouvelle génération beaucoup plus
vertueux en matière d'écologie et
j'évoque par exemple volontiers le
projet canopée qui demain devra
transporter
les pièces les différentes parties de la
fusée ariane 6 et ce navire sera à la
fois propulsé par du gaz qui est une
énergie de transition pour le transport
maritime
comparé au fioul au fioul lourd mais
également par des ailes de propulsion
des ailes rigides de propulsion et ce il
y a quelques mois
les porteurs de ce projet
ne trouvait pas de solution en europe il
envisageait de construire en turquie moi
je connais bien c'est en turquie ou
ailleurs
enfin à l'extérieur de l'europe alors
que typiquement c'est un projet qui
pourrait être construit en europe
moi je les ai beaucoup poussé à essayer
de trouver plus tôt à s'orienter vers
des éventuellement une un maillage de
différents sous traitants ça et
constructeur européen et aujourd'hui ils
vont bientôt signer la construction de
ce bateau donc est conçu en france qui
sera probablement aussi construit par un
chantier néerlandais mais construit en
pologne avec des sous-traitants dans
différents en allemagne et est c est en
france
donc moi ce que je crois vraiment c'est
que ce plan de relance industrielle et
c'est et ça répond à la souveraineté
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure à la
recherche de souveraineté convoqué tout
à l'heure c'est que pour financer pour
voir émerger au niveau européen des
projets vertueux on peut véritablement
avoir une une stratégie paneuropéenne je
pense qu en tous les cas sur sur les
grands projets industriels comme comme
ceux du maritime voilà un exemple
merci catherine est et est justement
peut-être l'occasion de parler d'un
enjeu actuel sur lequel vous êtes
positionnés et sur lequel vous
travaillez également à différentes c'est
c'est la méditerranée l'europe c'est
aussi la méditerranée avec depuis
quelques années une interprète
interpellation de l'union européenne par
rapport à la crise migratoire
on entend moins parler de la crise
migratoire actuellement est ce que la
crise sanitaire a éclipsé la crise à la
crise migratoire et puis également mais
je crois que ce sera davantage
développée dans l'atelier suivant les
relations de l'union européenne avec ses
voisins proches et notamment mes qu'elle
quel rôle joue aujourd'hui la
méditerranée dante dans la politique
européenne et est ce que c'est aussi et
c'est toujours au coeur des enjeux est
ce que la crise n terreur
un peu éclipsé la crise migratoire et
les enjeux géostratégiques de sept
heures de cet endroit pour tes preuves
et catherine à christophe est revenue
christophe airaud est-ce que c'est
christophe nous en tant qu il a le son
et l'image
il peut peut-être avant de peut être
révoqué la méditerranée s'il a réussi à
nous de suivre indiqué les justement
cité ces fameux 14 filières
industrielles qu'est ce que c'est c'est
14 filière puisse l'identifier par
thierry breton et comment l'union
européenne compte conférence élus
christophe bonjour un sens vous
m'entendez bien c'est bon au tour du pin
au cccc tu disais le grosses difficultés
de connexion sont fakih match pour faire
plaisir à vincent jay le lion de belfort
derrière moi donc le félix celui paiera
le monument préféré des français depuis
hier soir donc merci à stéphane bern et
aux gens qui ont voté donc alors les 14
est possible donc moi je m'occupe au
niveau du parlement européen de la
commission itre est donc je suis vice
coordinateur de cette commission c'est
industrie recherche énergie et donc on a
travaillé notamment avec thierry breton
sur la question de ce plan de relance
européen qui s'articule autour des 14
écosystèmes alors les quatorze
écosystèmes ça représente à peu près 60%
de la valeur ajoutée du pib des deux de
l'union européenne et donc il ya
pratiquement tous les thèmes qui sont
dedans c'est l'industrie dans le sens
anglo saxon du terme c'est à dire qu'il
y a le temps aussi bien l'économie
solidaire et sociale aussi bien le le
tourisme c'est pas seulement la
manufacture par contre on est
physiquement très attaché à ce que on
est on est de la vraie industrie de
fabrication qui dans l'union européenne
et qu'on puisse relancer tous ces
écosystèmes avec le fameux plan de
relance de 750 milliards qui a été
adopté avec des subventions avec avec
deux des prêts par dont j'espère que
vous n'aurez pas les pauvres parce que
moi je m'entends avec à peu près avec
maintenant un tout petit peu mais ça
nous
et comment comprendre quand même on
alors là donc donc il ya un plan de
réparation sur ces écosystèmes donc
permettent de revenir au niveau d'avant
la crise et puis après un plan de
reconquête
et sur ce plan de reconquête c'est de
l'aide à l'investissement avec la des
objectifs objectifs climatiques un le
plan de relance il est vert il est
numérique il est inclusif et quand je
dis inclusif c'est bien sûr pour le
parti social qui évoque sylvie mais
c'est également pour la partie régionale
il faut laisser de côté aucun
travailleur et aucune région
donc il ya c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette
volonté d'être inclusif sur le plan de
relance et puis également il est
stratégique c'est à dire que tout ça ça
correspond à une nouvelle donne au
niveau de l'industrie européenne
c'est l'autonomie stratégique on a
besoin d'industrie en europe 1 le dogme
et il ya quelques années et qui disait
on va garder la matière grise en europe
et puis on va fabriquer en asie c'est
fini on s'est aperçu que c'était une
impasse donc voilà on travaille un petit
peu là dessus je suis rapporteur de du
rapport sur la nouvelle stratégie
industrielle européenne sur les
questions d'intégration énergétique
je travaille beaucoup de solides
reviennent je travaille beaucoup sur
tout type d'énergie en général et donc
voilà donc ces obstacles pas être facile
je suis désolé de web forums donc si
jamais vous avez des questions vous
pouvez toujours me contacter il n'y a
pas de souci oui mais voilà à peu près
les génocides sur lesquels je reviens
avec la défense et les affaires
étrangères
j'ai une question j'ai une question
christophe parce que tu viens justement
de belfort et de la bourgogne franche
comté une région très industrielle
comment les députés européens peuvent
aussi défendre leur territoire
défendre leur région dans leur travail a
avancé notamment au niveau fiscal est ce
que il ya des leviers pour faire en
sorte que les filières rompu par les
écosystèmes dont tu parlais bien il se
développe où il soit soutenue
particulièrement dans les territoires
qui qui sont vos terres d'élection
ouvert de résidence
que ce soit sur la bourgogne franche
comté où que ce soit sur sur d'autres
territoires
représente de manière d'ailleurs assez
homogène notre délégation de ben alors
donc moi ville de cuers à belfort quai
des mines industrielles mais je suis
élue de la circonscription france
puisque maintenant il ya plus ces
circonscriptions par grandes régions et
donc alors au début nous voyons ça
éloigne en fait les élus du terrain
c'est ce que je pensais puis finalement
non parce que quand on est 23 dans une
délégation de renaissance 23 députés
européens sur la circo france quand il
ya une thématique qui intéresse l'un ou
l'autre
eh bien on est aussi bien vite et très
loin de chez nous où tous très près donc
moi je m'occupe de l'espace par exemple
la politique spatiale
binger développer d'excellentes
relations avec toulouse qui se sont
rendus compte que moi je m'intéressais
au spatial et qui m'invitent même si je
suis de belfort et donc ça permet en
fait d'avoir une proximité thématiques
à défaut d'une proximité géographique et
c'est un plus imaginons que de là dans
les législatures d'avant toulouse par
exemple et u11 députés dans son secteur
géographique mais qui ne s'occupait par
exemple que des questions agricoles
là c'était difficile de venir lui parler
d'industrie et des espaces puisque là
les gens ont maintenant un panel de 23
députés ils peuvent directement
interpellé celui qui qui est sur leurs
thématiques voilà est donc évidemment
dans ma ville je vais quand même de gros
problèmes avec géré électrique avec
alstom ça va un peu mieux
et donc voilà il ya aussi un petit
combat local pour aider un peu les les
porteurs de projets mais je les aide
autant d'efforts que je les ai deux en
bretagne par exemple ou à marseille où
le y voir pour parler des deux de mes
collègues est donc mais partout en fait
au mental et où les gens s'intéressent
aux fêtes aux thématiques industriels
sur lesquels je travaille c'est pas
facile mais quand vous connaissez un
petit peu la technique européenne
voilà il ya quand même beaucoup de
crédibilité qu'on peut qu'on peut
apporter à l'action des députés
européens en allant au plus près du
terrain un peu partout en france
merci à christophe alors on va peut-être
passer aux questions des internautes
équipe i petitjean nous nous demandent
quelles nouvelles sur les courses vers
ans sur le futur de l'europe c'est vrai
que emmanuel macron avait annoncé je
crois c'est dans son discours de la
sorbonne de faire ses formes de grands
débats qu'on a connu un peu augmenté
chez les jaunes mais mais sous forme de
conférences citoyennes et puis après on
a parlé aussi de conférence nationale
sur l'avenir d'europe et maintenant de
deux et on n'est pas d'ailleurs aussi
des régions de conférence ordinaire de
l'horreur comme celles qui avaient pu
déboucher sur le traité constitutionnel
européen qui finalement n'avait pas été
fait par les états on en est ou sur
cette question institutionnelle et sur
cette surce t on cette conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe paraît pierre potet
alors il faut déjà préciser que la
conférence sur l'avenir sur donc sur
l'avenir de l'europe c'est une volonté
que porte aussi notre groupe politique
rogne on a toujours accentuée sur le
lien justement avec les citoyens parce
que pour nous c'est capital
justement d'incarner l'europe dans nos
territoires et la conférence sur
l'avenir pour l'europe doit permettre
justement de créer un vrai débat avec
les citoyens sur ce que nous voulons
construire ensemble entre européens
alors pour répondre précisément à la
question qui est posée par cali où on
est tous c'était une priorité affichée
avant le coc vie de 19
je suis la fontaine laguiole en a
reparlé très très brièvement dans son
discours sur l'état de l'union
quand elle a évoqué l'europe de la santé
donc nous en tant que membre du groupe
julio on va pousser pousser pour que
cette conférence ait lieu mais l'enjeu
c'est comment elle va avoir lieu
et qu'est ce qu'il en ressort parce que
vincent tu évoqué les consultations qui
ont eu lieu juste avant les élections
européennes qui ont permis à des partis
tels que les notes de bâtir notre
programme pour les élections européennes
mais derrière il faut savoir sur ce quoi
ça va déboucher comment les citoyens
comment les associations aussi vont être
impliqués dans la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe
hélas nous ne disions est très clair on
veut
que la conférence sur l'avenir sur
l'europe implique pleinement les
citoyens on aimerait et on a poussé
depuis le début de notre mandat pour que
guy verhofstadt qui est membre de notre
groupe politique puisse être la personne
qui incarne aussi la conférence sur
l'avenir pour l'europe
est ce qu'on dit aussi c'est que au
travers de cette conférence il doit pas
y avoir de tabou il doit pas y avoir de
tout m6 la conférence sur l'avenir
l'europe arrive et propose une
modification des traités mais il faut le
porter mais derrière ça me véritablement
dire comme je le dis quelle europe
nous voulons bâtir ensemble est-ce qu'on
veut que le domaine de la santé comme on
l'a vu avec le choc du coded soit une
compétence de l'union européenne est ce
qu'on veut faire en sorte je suis la
bonne al nahyan en a parlé que la
majorité qualifiée soit véritablement
maintenant un principe c'est tout ça où
il faut qu'on ait des positions claires
pour bâtir cette europe de l'avenir on
parlait même un moment je crois de
tirage au sort un peu façon convention
citoyenne est ce que c'est une position
qu'on défend pour cette convention est
ce qu'il faudra il mêlé aussi des
citoyens tirés au sort pour réfléchir
sur l'avenir de l'union
est-ce qu'il faut impliquer aussi les
élus locaux tu as parlé des associations
des syndicats
comment
et ça va avancer
est ce que on est sur quelque chose de
concret qui doit déboucher bientôt ou
encore à l'état de discussion avec
archivage peut-être que parce que leur
en suis également
je sais pas de quoi en tout cas sur le
système laurent tirage au sort
rien rien n'est arrêté à l'heure
actuelle et puis là aussi je complète ce
que j'ai à dire c'est quels moyens on va
allouer à la conférence pour l'avenir de
l'europe mais je laisse laurence je
pense qu'ils voulaient peut-être dire un
mot dessus laurange pratique et
technique je pense qu'on est encore loin
de ces questions puisque en été quand
même
marie qu'il y en a encore beaucoup de
deux groupes concrétisent une différence
de pour l'avenir de l'europe qui a
vraiment un combat de notre politique
en relation directe bien sûr avec
n'avait été posée par le plan macro mais
je voulais dire que et donc nous allons
combattre et nous mobiliser beaucoup
dans sur ce sujet dans les prochains
mois mais je voulais dire que la
question de la poule de la conférence
pour l'europe c'est carrément la sto du
sentiment d'appartenance des citoyens en
conclura cette entité qui reste une
vraiment une question que les dents dans
le renforcement et la construction
européenne et c'est pour ça que il faut
appréhender dans tout ce qu'on dit la
dimension des programmes humains aussi
qu'ils sont le sentiment le ciment de
l'europe
on voit bien l'europe comme l'a dit le
fondateur jean monnet elle se construit
par des actions concrètes et la dernière
rencontre en date c'était quand même la
décision sur landreau lance maintenant
la question du sentiment d'appartenance
de l'identité européenne
elle est vraiment en perpétuelle
construction donc je voulais donner à
titre d'exemple des programmes qui reste
très important pour la boutique parce
que lui il me concerne de presse c'est
le programme erasmus plus bien sûr le
programme le plan de relance s'appelle
next generation
donc programme pour la prochaine
génération au sein de l'union européenne
par un programme emblématique et
kerascoët plus on se bat actuellement
pour que son budget soit absolument
préserver il nous manque
le compte n'y est pas en quoi c'est un
combat en cours on en a plein et au sein
du combat de d'erasmus plus il ya des
nouvelles initiatives comme les
universités européennes comme les
centres de formation pour
l'apprentissage qui peuvent nous amener
vers un statut européen des apprentis
donc on voit que l'europe elle se
constitue aussi à travers ce les
échanges humains et et concret et 2 et
des échanges de savoirs et des échanges
d'expériences
je vous les citer aussi no kuni ce natif
que nous avons eues et qui datent de la
semaine dernière nous avons été à
l'initiative d'un d'une résolution pour
la relance de la culture européenne pour
faire en sorte que cet sujet très
important de la culture est très
lourdement affectué affectés
actuellement soit pris en compte dans
les plans de relance et que 2 % des
fonds qui seraient attribuées aux états
membres pour leur plan de relance inclut
cette dimension de la culture on a aussi
dit dans cette résolution a été votée
le volet culturel devrait absolument
être intégré dans le dans la conférence
pour l'avenir de l'euro voilà donc y
perdre sa dimension institutionnelle
commence comptera la conférence pour
l'avenir de l'europe c'est à construire
en effet et puis là le renforcement de
ses programmes humains et de relations
qui font tout à fait les dents le
renforcement de l'appartement c'est du
sentiment d'appartenance des citoyens à
l'europe merci lancer effectivement la
place de la culture dans le plan de
relance d'un sujet d'actualité avec les
journées européennes du patrimoine qui
se déroulent en ce moment et qui sont
l'occasion pour chacun de redécouvrir
leur patrimoine
de proximité et on est beaucoup
d'ailleurs d'élus locaux genre bd pour
ma paroisse a espéré des crédits
supplémentaires encore pour rénover le
patrimoine
maintenant que stéphane bern a mis en
valeur belfort et notre ami christophe
doulet
eh bien il faut aussi que l'ensemble du
patrimoine puisse bénéficier de ce plan
de relance parce que derrière ce sont
également des emplois et de
l'apprentissage cher à sylvie brunet des
jeunes qui se forment mais aussi le
rayonnement de la culture
par delà nos frontières
merci beaucoup à toutes et à tous de
d'avoir participé sylvie brunel
catherine chabaud leurs parents
christophe grudler marie-pierre vedrenne
nos eurodéputé modem ou les remercie
également la technique et je salue les
départements dans lesquels axe
effectivement comme les bouches-du-rhône
où d'autres départements la l'épidémie
de covilha a conduit à des annulations
on voit donc que cette relance n'est pas
sans embûches et que la situation
sanitaire au niveau français comme au
niveau européen sera à surveiller dans
les mois à venir
vous pourrez les eurodéputés me font
dire que ils répondront aux questions
plus tard notamment celles qui sont
posées sur les réseaux sociaux qui
peuvent alors être posées directement
je crois qu'ils sont assez facilement
joignable sur prénom points n'ont
atteint euros par point europa.eu enfin
vous trouvez facilement aussi les
coordonnées de leurs assistants et de
leurs bureaux à bruxelles
et ils me font dire que ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup de questions qu'elle aurait
voulu répondre
mais là le format particulier et ce
temps très court ne nous a pas forcément
permis d'aborder tous les sujets j'ai
été ravi de pouvoir faire cette cité
démocrate avec vous et j'espère qu'on
aura l'occasion l'an prochain de
débattre de l'année
plus conventionnel et de voir que
l'ensemble des sujets que nous avons
abordé ce midi ont avancé merci à tous
et suites et des mains